do you believe that only the Earth is
flatbone what about the other planets
the thing about people who believe the
Earth is flat is that it's not actually
a belief that the Earth is flat it's
actually just an assertion about
doubting everything that exists
everything we know science institutions
I did a big deep dive on this and
learned a lot about photographers and
yeah there's some people doing science
about it whatever but most people are
doing the flatter thing as just a big Fu
to
science that that they can't see and
understand and measure themselves and so
they just doubt it and it feels really
good for them and so that's why these
arguments don't really go anywhere